okay I've had mixed feelings about how
to cover this next story and I'll
explain why I did a couple of stories in
the last month about Donald Trump
starting to talk about how he likes the
idea of the death penalty for
drug-related crimes and it's a relevant
story in that listen if the president
wants to do something so depraved so
counterproductive so ludicrous but at
the same time Trump can't unilaterally
change the law to put in the death
penalty for more drug crimes how much
time should I really spend talking about
it I want to let you know that Trump
wants to start killing people for
drug-related crimes but I also don't
want to make it seem like Trump can just
unilaterally change the law and give it
more attention than it requires so with
that exact same caveat today I'm
reporting you that Trump's beleaguered
that the use Trump's own term Trump's
beleaguered Attorney General Jeff
Sessions is now instructing federal
prosecutors to seek the death penalty in
drug cases so okay that's what Jeff
Sessions is saying but what does that
mean and how would it actually work
because as far as crimes go Trump has
said he wants to execute opioid dealers
and traffickers and sessions told
federal prosecutors ask for the death
penalty when you see it as appropriate
but you can't just do that whenever you
want right there is so much nonsense
here that it's tough to know where to
start
number one there aren't many federal
death penalty cases right most that most
death penalty cases are State cases
there are only 61 prisoners in the
entire country that are on federal death
row mostly it states imposing the death
penalty secondly starting to pursue the
death penalty federally it's going to be
very very expensive it's not fiscally
conservative in any way federal death
penalty cases like all death penalty
cases take a lot longer they cost a lot
more money so if the ideas fiscal
conservatism it's going to be a move in
the opposite direction but the big
problem is this thing this very
complicated thing called the law which
hasn't changed and the law limits the
death penalty for drug related cases
really really narrowly
to seek the death penalty in a drug case
you need either a case where a firearm
resulted in a death during a drug
trafficking crime a case where a murder
was committed as part of a criminal
enterprise that could have included drug
trafficking it has to be a case
involving racketeering or a case
involving just an absurd gigantic
quantity of drugs which are not the most
common scenarios so on the one hand I
want to discuss with you that the Trump
administration is pushing horrible
policy but on the other hand they just
don't really have the power to
arbitrarily do this all they can really
do is in cases that already could
qualify for the death penalty
tell prosecutors to ask for it instead
of long prison sentences and of course
it would also be up to the prosecutors
to figure out whether they think that's
even something that they could get and
that's an uphill battle to climb as well
you've really got to thread the needle
very precisely here and I also hate to
break it to these supposed law and order
conservatives but even stricter
penalties for drug crimes if they were
legally possible aren't going to fix the
problem right the drug war fighting the
war on drugs as a criminal justice issue
as a law enforcement issue rather than
as a health issue and a legalization
issue got us into this mess to begin
with right so we've got to stop looking
at this issue as a criminal law
enforcement issue if we really want to
fix it and I also started thinking if
you're a drug dealer and you've got
nothing left to lose because the police
police are closing in on you and you
know you might get the death penalty
just for the trafficking wouldn't that
encourage you to try to shoot your way
out and maybe kill a police officer or
innocent bystander anyway because listen
in the end either way you might be
facing the death penalty it makes no
sense
there's no dumber idea as far as the
drug war is concerned the one bit of
good news is that Trump saying this and
sessions saying this aren't going to
lead to any major changes in the actual
law and so that's about as far as I'm
going to go with it if we actually start
to see an effort to change the law then
you can rest assured I'm going to come
back and talk to you about it today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in
part by brilliant which is a great
online service that allows you to master
concepts in math science and engineering
by solving fun and challenging problems
and unlike other learning sites when I'm
using brilliant I'm learning by working
hands-on with real-world scenarios and
problems you solve challenging puzzles
that have been designed by expert
educators and professionals from all
over the world they don't move too fast
they don't move too slowly they take you
step-by-step through the topics you're
interested in at your own pace and one
of their principles is effective
learning is active watching YouTube
videos which is great by the way I
encourage it and I do it all the time
that's a more passive form of learning
that gets you so far
that's when brilliant comes in and
you're watching you're learning not by
watching but by actually doing and you
can get started right now at brilliant
org slash David Pakman first 200 to
visit the website brilliant org slash
David Pakman we'll get 20% off an annual
premium membership but of course sign up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman